[Music]
it's been three weeks I spent 40 minutes
on my wake up to meet his friends and
co-workers at a grand opening for the
retail company he works for he was too
embarrassed to be seen with me this
outfit so he sent me home an Uber and
went to the opening without me
[Music]
in the follow-up video here we go
[Music]
I said I'm wearing this to the function
or going home he said can I call you an
Uber
so I'll be in an Uber so I'm in an Uber
going home okay so she made him like
ultimately I guess
so sad because
this would set me home in an Uber who
does that he sent me home with a
stranger on a Friday night fine I'm good
I'm not gonna cry like a little bit he
already did
you can't say you're not gonna do
something you already did
I'm not gonna punch High by no arm
I just did Brad how you gonna do that
[ __ ] again I'm like yo we're gonna have
a problem the worst stop for an example
is acceptable don't do that [ __ ] again
see all right here we go my van is a
mess because I've like literally moved
into his house for the past three weeks
and I shoved everything in there so now
I gotta clean it all someone in the
comment wrote she's all Tink
she's what ultimate that means she's
using her special move old thing yeah
like you look like a kamiyami hot type
of thing I ain't mad at it that's so
special because that's what it is
but you know what let me not be
uncharitable let me listen a little
thing my van is a mess because I've like
literally moved into his house for the
past two weeks and I shoved everything
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
you know I'm slow right
this house for the past three weeks she
said it was three weeks she lives in a
van wait wait yep I ran she said adding
that she now lives into her van with her
loyal cat I'm glad I got out after only
three weeks and not three years
why did you move then I have to
let me let me talk let me talk to my
white people for two seconds y'all move
in with people you just meant way too
quickly way too [ __ ] quickly
[ __ ] we just met like three
months ago we're gonna move in next
month [ __ ] what
how does that [ __ ] make sense
y'all move in with each other we'll do
really too
immigrants take way too much time concur
but can we find a middle of our Middle
Ground can we find it in between three
weeks you moving a [ __ ] forget
the fact that he rejected you for your
drip you move in with someone you met
through social media apps
after three weeks before
not even three weeks they they dated you
met the week after you move in and then
you move after we
what
I don't even understand and comprehend
how the hell that makes sense and now
you don't see that that's a problem I
really don't I don't see how you see
that and you say that and you're like
yeah that's perfectly fine there's not a
problem and a thing wrong with what I
said
you met someone the week after you moved
it yeah
but the truth is and this is reality is
it's not that abnormal a lot of people
do this and it's not white people it's
not white people no I see people who
like fall quickly will do that people
well then then I'm sorry white people I
don't want to put that on you apparently
it's not all y'all
um that's crazy that that's Mental
Health
there's a there is something that is
lacking that you need to attach yourself
to someone that quickly that you don't
have any
holding backs in any
um let me see where this goes any
retention any that's mental health yeah
but I've been doing that and I've been
with my girl for four years good on you
I ain't talking about you sometimes we
talking but we're not talking to you
okay okay that's crazy okay so on the
topic of the moving in I think he
covered that pretty extensively
on the topic of the actual event itself
I can understand why she would be upset
you know you get ready you're excited to
do this and be present and you're
basically being told you're not
appropriate
that's fair I can understand why you'd
be disappointed and be hurt by all that
however it's his work function if he
doesn't want to bring you based off your
outfit it's because it would affect him
from a work perspective you got to be
sensitive to that right no she's just
sensitive like there's certain things I
know I can't wear
to my partner's work functions
right even though you know y'all know me
that's the old boy
um if it's my partner's work function I
gotta come appropriate and she says no
you can't come in and drivers or you
can't come in these kinds of pants I
gotta change it sucks it's an
inconvenience but I understand for you
to sit there and say well I'm wearing
this or I'm going home okay then [ __ ]
you gotta go I got a job to keep what's
wrong with you
and I already know both of you are
weirdos because he let you move in after
two three weeks and you moved in so I
already know you guys are weirdos so
honestly I don't really feel that much
sympathy for anyone involved in this
whole situation I get it people fall
people make mistakes I don't gotta feel
a bunch of sympathy for it
because you look like a grown-ass woman
by your age you should know better
and if you don't
I can see why you in a van with your cat
people just jump the stages because they
want to get to the end destination
realizing the end destination doesn't
really end it just keeps going in
perpetuity there is no end destination
so but they have a point they want to
get to they think you know what I mean
Nation when it's actually a journey it's
like they want to skip the whole going
on dates and getting to know each other
they want to jump right into the
relationship they wanna look maybe that
works some people but there's nothing
wrong with actually going through
certain steps maybe going through four
dates then you get to know each other
yeah then you get into a relationship
and [ __ ] want to go on a whole
boat ride they don't even know if they
can float yeah [ __ ] it's like y'all
jumping a bunch of steps from finding
out like everything is Half Baked yeah
you didn't leave it in the oven long
enough boo-boo that happens
[ __ ] came out kind of raw and not the
good kind
I'm looking at this is like yo
you wearing a crop top I could
definitely see that being inappropriate
for some work events I don't know what
his job is
I don't know what his position is
but I could definitely see that crop top
being a no at a lot of events
so you just gotta be mindful that's all
I'm trying to say guys it doesn't
encourage you guys you know he could
have messaged her like hey send me a
picture of your outfit or maybe she
could have sent a picture his outfit if
it was that porn there's a communication
barrier that they probably didn't get
through because one they don't know each
other for long enough but it's like
you're not gonna have no
miscommunications you're not gonna have
no mishaps but it's gonna talk about he
sent me home in an Uber at least he paid
for and at least he got you home in an
Uber you act like he told you a [ __ ]
start walking
I don't know everyone's being hyperbolic
to make the other party look bad and
everyone in the comments is like [ __ ]
never go back to him oh he's a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] him and I'm like none of y'all
peep the fact that this lady moved in
after three weeks y'all crazy are you
guys also insane y'all crazy
straight up crazy
I mean I've dated girls for a whole year
and a half before I even considered the
idea of them moving in with me that's
all
that's quick
that's quick no that's crazy I mean
boo-boo you'd even finish your whole
period cycle
and you already moved in
that's fast so that's all I must say
like I'm a kind of [ __ ] that's
gonna wait to go on a I'm gonna go to go
one I'm gonna I'm gonna wait to go on a
trip with you yeah all-inclusive yeah
okay and that's that's
if I go and I can send you that's like
the first step if I go
on an all-inclusive trip I know some of
y'all not like good with all inclusive
[ __ ] but if I go with a partner I want
to go on an all-inclusive trip with you
okay the reason why the reason why is
because
an all-inclusive trip is actually life
on super easy mode nobody Cooks nobody
cleans everybody's happy everything is
nice
slide on easy mode if I can't stand you
for a week on life on easy mode I ain't
moving with you that's first step if I
haven't gone on a trip with you I'm
surely not gonna move in with you
then I'm gonna move in I'm gonna do
another trip with you I'm I'm a bit
extra that's me but if I don't do those
steps I'm not gonna I don't know you
yeah I don't know you I don't know you
should be flying these ladies out like
yeah we're going on trips if if I don't
go if I don't go you stupid for that one
if I don't go after that in an Airbnb
trip with you we're not moving in
because that's the second level of life
because now you got to take care of your
food you got to take care of this and
that what you gonna do you know I mean
there's nobody to entertain you on the
site you understand what I'm saying you
do a little trial period is what you're
saying absolute fuckingly try before you
buy yes okay and it's the same thing for
her don't I'm the same way don't be
thinking that she don't do the same
thing she does the same thing as she
should I'm the same way with [ __ ]
huh I tried before I buy
[Laughter]
it
all
yeah
yeah
[Music]
but that but I'm one week what is one oh
my days Hey Hey listen you know what
lady
if you see this and maybe there's
context that we're missing to this but
based off the article and the videos
that you posted how quickly you moved in
and then moved out maybe there's some
other things you gotta look at because
Mental Health
the therapist
stop sticking with me mental health okay
I'm not stigmatizing you I'm I'm telling
you you should check that out
check that out
all right this is something that we say
in Creole and Haitian Creole Foods
what happened to you
I could see it happening to you so no
sympathy for me